section three again remember there are
microphones in the room just raise your
hand and then uh otherwise you can also
just shout loudly the
ceiling microphones will pick it up okay
thomas thanks for doing that
over here
okay great
yeah i also wanted to say thank you to
the uh the organizers the other
organizers um for for putting this
together and also thank you to simon for
sort of setting us up and hosting and
being willing to tolerate people like me
that are doing this remotely
i'd certainly do hope to get to the
institute um in february once yeah
things settle down a little bit okay
so uh this the talk here um has uh two
parts but i'm not going to get to the
second part so i'm going to talk about
single world intervention graphs this is
a framework for relating graphs and uh
counter factuals or potential outcomes
via node splitting
and i'll show some simple examples give
you a general procedure
and we'll then talk about adjustment for
confounding
and then connecting back to
uh that what spencer presented on on
tuesday i'll then
show how um
using potential icons we can simplify
the
the uh do calculus and and also
reformulate it but um
and then i'll give us an illustration
deriving the front door criterium which
is also uh talked about on
by
tuesday
potential outcome
calculus po calculus as we call it and
i'll talk about sequentially randomized
experiments
okay
um
so
up to this point this is just again in
review we had the graph on the left
which represents no compounding the
graph on the right is confounding
this is remember the conf the
the
convention that when we draw a dag and
we interpret it coarsely we're sort of
obliged to always include hidden
variables if hidden variables are
present
and then
um
then this this approach
uh originates with uh um work of saul
wright in the 1920s geneticist
um
and
yeah this is terminology that you
already know
okay
[Music]
i said not going to make you quite that
light a little bit too light
okay is that better
okay um
so
yeah so so the key thing is that if i
have this graph on the left it
represents uh that where there's no con
confounding vary between x and y this
represents the idea that there's no
confounding
as you saw we have this associated
factorization which is trivial
and in the absence of confounding the
causal model assets and here i'm writing
the assertion both in terms of potential
outcomes and in terms of do that we saw
on
uh tuesday it's saying that the
distribution over y if everyone were to
get um we're forced to take the value x
uh it's the same as the conditional
distribution for y given x equals x
which is the same as uh and so this
these are two ways of just saying the
distribution where we intervene to set x
to x
this is the potential outcome we're
writing it this is the do calculus where
i write it and then the the fact that
there's no confounding says that these
things which are the same object is
equal to the conditional distribution of
y given x
and this is basically what we saw back
on the in the first lecture this morning
that the average causal effect is
identified under this
model
so a question that you might ask is what
how does this relate to the
um how does this relate to the the
potential outcome approach i mean i've
i've sort of shown you this over here so
i'm already relating it a little bit but
in particular you'll recall hopefully
that um when i talked about the absence
of confounding we talked in terms of
these independences we talked about
treatment
being independent of the potential
outcomes
um so this is
in
the
uh potential outcome terminology this
would be called uh treatment assignment
is is uh ignorable weakly ignorable and
then confounding corresponded to the at
least one of these independents is not
holdings
okay and so
if you sort of followed the discussion
on tuesday you'll have realized that
graphs are this very powerful
representation for dealing with um
for reading off independences and
conditional independences
um and they also have a causal
interpretation and so here the potential
outcome framework
characterizes
the absence of confined confounding
precisely in terms of these or
can be thought of as characterizing it
precisely in terms of these
independences
and we've got a graph here
so the natural question is okay this is
a causal graph here we've got an
independence that independence captures
this absence of confounding
can i read this off from the graph
that seems like a very
reasonable thing
to think that one might be able to do
but there's a problem which is that if
you remember anything about the
separation and deconnection from tuesday
you'll be aware that you can't really
read something off the graph if the
variable doesn't appear on the graph
and so we have the
what we could call the elephant in the
room here that doesn't matter how long
you stare at this graph there are no
potential outcome variables on the graph
so there's no way you're going to get to
read the sources so this has sometimes
been used
um you know that there are certain
people who will remain nameless who have
said that you know these graphs couldn't
possibly be causal because
we know that uh causality in in at least
since neyman is captured in terms of
potential outcomes and there are no
potential outcomes on the graph
therefore these are not causal i'm not
i'm not advocating for that uh
you know i'm going to show that i think
that's
overly simplistic um
and misses the point
but it has been argued
okay so what are we going to do we're
going to show a way of
of transforming the graph we're going to
add some additional semantics onto the
graph
via a notion of of splitting a node that
will then allow us to read off the uh
the
independence
that we naturally associate with the
absence of confounding from the graph
directly just using the separation so
here's the idea we start off with this
graph over here on the left this is the
associated factorization
the tilde 0 just because i'm going to
want to refer to more than one level of
x so therefore i'm
using tilde here
and now i'm going to split x this random
node this is the graphical operation i'm
going to split it into two pieces this
piece x which is random
and then there's going to be a fixed
piece
where
where
um x is uh equal to zero
and then everything that's downstream of
this fixed piece in particular this y is
going to then become a potential outcome
and so now we can now read from this
graph over here on the on the left we
can read the independence because x here
this is uh this is a separate node so
the purpose in splitting will become
clear later but the purpose in splitting
is partly just so that i can look at the
graph on the left and easily work out
what was the original graph from which
it was obtained
but we're just going to think about the
random nodes just as if they were random
nodes in an ordinary dag so here's x
here's y of x equals zero
if you remember anything about the
connection you'll
be aware there has to be a path between
these two there is no path so therefore
we read therefore x and this guy are
uh d separated so we can read off this
minus independence
okay
um
so
we can also associate you also you know
we associated with dags of factorization
the random variables we've got over here
are x and y of x equals zero
so the factorization we're going to get
is just going to be this um
this is just the the simple
factorization that um
that we will get
okay uh so
so you know x and y of x equals zero are
um
you know are
there's no edge between these two so we
get this very simple factorization
and then you might say well that's all
very well you've constructed this new
graph you've got this new variable here
how is that connected to the original
graph the original distribution that we
started out with
and the way that we're going to do that
is we're going to say
that the distribution of y of x equals
zero minus the distribution of y of x
equals zero we'll obtain from the
distribution of y given x in the
original graph by just taking a
conditional distribution of y given x
equals zero
in the original graph
okay so essentially we've built a new
graph by splitting a node in this graph
we built a new distribution
by uh by sort of repurposing by by
taking the terms that were in our
original factorization to the observed
distribution we just
copied that term directly over and then
this the second term here we obtained by
now setting x to zero in this this uh
term in the factorization
and that then gives us our new
factorization associated with a new
graph
and so
sometimes i'll refer to
the first
there are two things we did here we
first just
sort of posited a new distribution over
x and this potential outcome and we said
it factorized according to the new graph
so we'll call that factorization and
then the second thing we did was we
linked
the
this new term in our new factorization
back to a term in the original
factorization and that uh that we could
call that that was sometimes called
modularities so
so the thing i want you to think about
is what i'm presenting here today is
like a bridge linking
causal graphs to potential outcomes and
this because it's a bridge it can be
crossed in either way the way i'm
presenting it to you at the moment is in
the way whereby i've got a a dag and i'm
interpreting it causely i'm sort of
comfortable doing that but now maybe i
go and i want to communicate with
biostatisticians who who think in terms
of potential outcomes and i want to be
able to translate the assumptions that
are
encoded in my causal graph into
assumptions
in terms of potential outcomes and i can
do that by crossing the bridge from
causal dags to potential outcomes by
splitting and then i can use my familiar
tools of de-separation and then you know
this factorization to then uh make
assertions about potential outcomes that
that my uh that sort of biostatisticians
who work with potential outcomes can
then use
but we could also go back in the other
direction if you're someone that is
familiar with potential outcomes already
and i present this framework to you
then you'll look at you might look at
this equation here
and you might say okay
wait a second that equation looks to be
like something that would follow from
the factorization from this independence
plus consistency and you would also be
completely right about that so if i
start off with a marginal here if i
start off with this minus or
distribution then well because i because
the graph the sets of this minus
distribution
this this random variable is independent
of x then i can then you know then this
term is equal to this term
and then i could then use consistency
i could then use consistency to then get
this to this form
okay so it's a question from uh lennon
here saying is x equals zero a variable
and so uh
for just for the moment i want you want
to say no okay so at the moment i'm
thinking about this is just just
something i have in the graph that i'm
putting in here it's really there so
that i know why it is that that these
subsequent variables are labeled with uh
of uh with um this potential outcome y
of x equals zero
it give me a few more slides and i'll
start we will start doing something with
this particular thing at the moment but
for the moment you can just think about
this as you know this is just a little
label that i've got in here to remind me
how i came up with this this
distribution over the random nodes that
are here we will later obviously do
things with this red node but for now
just
don't focus on this red node for now
we'll come back to it
okay
so
uh here i'm doing you know we split we
set x to zero we got some results out we
could obviously split and have x equal
to one that would then give us this
graph
okay where we could now read off this
independence
and we could then get a new
factorization over the variables that
are in this new graph these two
it factors in this way
and we again then you know we will get
this additional assumption that would
say well i'm going to build this piece
this term
from the original factorization in this
way
or again
if you are a
potential outcomes person you could take
the this reached over the the you know
if you're playing some outcomes person
the basic objects for you are x and
these potential outcomes for y
and then i could use this independence
and um consistency to then get me back
to get me this equality
that's that's if you're crossing the
bridge if you know you wake up in the
morning and the things you see of thanks
outcomes but you then want to sort of
understand how you could uh translate
those back into causal graphs
okay so i did it with x equals zero i
did it with x equals one
um
you know
i'm not going to insist that you
construct a separate graph for every
value of x that would be very time
consuming especially if x took you know
infinitely many values but there is a
point here and the reason we we're doing
this so this the new graph that we were
constructing this one where we split
we're going to call a single world
intervention graph
and and the reason for that term single
world i'm now going to explain to you
so there were two graphs i showed you
the first one i'm calling g of x0 that
was representing this this
distribution the second one
was representing this distribution
and the key point that we saw is that
under no confounding these meissner
distributions
are identified
from the joint distribution over x and y
so in contrast
yes that was my ipad having
getting above itself basically i don't
know why
um
sorry uh yes in contrast sorry
in contrast
um
if you're a graphical person is that
where i stopped
yeah
if you're a graphical person you might
say
well wait a second you know um
we've got these three random variables x
y of x zero y of x one
graphs are great why don't i just try to
use a graph to represent the joint
distribution over these uh over these
random variables and that is
[Music]
your sound is breaking up again
sorry again
just a second
okay is it are you hearing me now yes
this is good okay i'm gonna kill i'm
gonna kill bluetooth here
okay i think we're
kept the uh
i pause at the gate out okay
airpods okay so um
so basically you might think to yourself
well wait a second why don't i just
build a graph for this whole
um
for this whole joint distribution and
that is an approach that pearl took with
the twin networks
but there are some problems with that
and one of the problem main problems is
that it's very hard we'll see it's very
hard to do that in a way without
introducing
additional assumptions and some of those
assumptions are things that could not be
tested
via any um randomized experiment
and we'll see that in fact that approach
um
quickly leads to
sort of super exponentially many
assumptions that are not really required
um
and yeah i'll i'll talk about that a
little bit more but essentially the idea
is
we're going to construct two different
graphs one representing this margin one
one representing this margin one
representing this margin
we're still thinking that there is an
underlying joint distribution
but we are just we're not uh going to
use a graph uh for that underlying joint
distribution because we want to use the
graphs to make the kind of assumptions
that we could test by a randomized
experiment and if we put a joint
distribution put a graph over all of
these variables we will very quickly
start making additional assumptions so
in particular
you know
i had one graph that represented this
independence one graph that represented
this independence if i put them all on
the same uh same graph all three
variables on the same graph then you
know that if x is d separated from this
and x is two separated from that then x
will be separated from both of them so
as a sort of simple example we will be
forced to have this uh joint
independence and you might say to
yourself well okay but big deal this is
sort of weak ignorability there's a
strong ignorability if i randomize x
then you know i would expect a strong
ignorability to hold that's a very
reasonable point it does seem a bit
pedantic in this context but once we
talk about examples as more variables
and mediation
we'll see it's very easy to very quickly
start making what we'll call cross-world
independence assumptions
and the framework i'm presenting is very
carefully set up to try to avoid making
or to avoid making cross-world
independence assumptions that could not
be checked by a randomized experiment
okay so yes had we constructed tried to
construct a single graph it would have
been impossible to have these two
independences and not this one at least
if we were using d separation we might
be able to come up with some more
sophisticated semantics but at least
with semantics that are currently known
for grass you couldn't have done it
and this is where the word single world
comes from
because here we're not we're not
constructing a graph that contains both
of these
potential outcomes
okay
so back to the question that was raised
in the chat which is about the nature of
this fixed node obviously i'm not really
proposing if x takes a thousand values
you could construct a thousand different
graphs you can certainly represent uh
all of them using this template
but the key thing is when we look at
this template i want you to think about
this as a sort of graph valued function
rather than a graph so the idea is you
come to me with a particular value of
little a particular value of x you're
interested in i plug that in and then
this thing then gives you out a graph
representing the joint over x and the
potential outcome y of x set to that
specific value
so each instantiation of the template is
going to represent a different margin
okay and so just to sort of aside here
um you might think to yourself well
you know you're saying this was
connected to testability
but this graph is representing a
situation where i get to see the natural
value of x it's representing a joint
over x and y of of little x that's a
what kind of world does this represent
where you know we could know someone's
natural value of x we could know the
natural the value of x that they would
choose but then we could also intervene
to set x to a specific value and then
see their potential outcomes
so for example how could it be
that we could both see that someone
would naturally choose to take treatment
if left to their own devices but also
find out what would happen to them in
the absence of treatment and so here we
come to the point where uh it uh
it helps that uh one of my courses is a
there's an md and came up with this uh
this hypothetical thought experiment
where um
where essentially we
so consider an experiment this is a
thought experiment i wish to stress that
but where
um
we simply monitor a a patient uh through
their you know facebook feed or whatever
camera is pointing at them at the
current time
and then at the moment where we see them
take the drug and swallow it we
instantly intervene a little bit like
you know
the swoop in like a minority report and
we then uh administer a safe hemetic
that causes the pill to be regurgitated
before any of the drug can enter the
bloodstream so the idea is that we can
see that the person would have chosen to
take the drug but we can intervene
before there are any causal effects of
them having taken that drug
and since it's we're assuming that
something has no side effects the
patient's recorded outcome is then going
to be y of x equals zero
okay so this is just a thought
experiment but it's it's helpful i think
because it ties into this idea of
splitting the idea of splitting is that
we're imagining an instant in time where
we get to see what the natural value of
treatment will be and then we intervene
okay so let's let's uh you know let's
look at a slightly harder inferential
problem so let's consider this graph
so here i've got two treatments a and b
and then um a influences
a we have a response said and then a
response y the response set is just
comes after
uh a
response y comes after uh z and b and
then we have a hidden variable that uh
confounds z and b
so the question here is does this graph
imply
this independence
so
now now i'm suddenly telling you about a
graph where i've got two treatments
but i can do that
so this is i'm giving you an example of
a more complicated
case and then i'm going to give you the
full algorithm but i think this the
example helps to explain
to give you the idea of the algorithm so
what are we doing here we split a
we split b
and then everything that's downstream
from the the fixed part of a gets
labeled with an a
and everything that's downstream from
the fixed fighter b gets labeled with a
b okay so we've now got a graph
representing a joint distribution over a
z of a
h b of a
y of a b
and now
we can use our d separation tool kit
that was uh explained on on uh on on
tuesday to read off from here okay why i
have a b is that d separated from b of a
given z of a and a well
there are two paths from here to here
there's this path and there's this path
on both of those parts say today is a
non-collider
so yes y of a b and b of a are d
separated given z of a we didn't
actually have to condition on a
that's in there for sort of historical
reasons that i can
can go into but
you can see that we can easily read off
from this graph that this independence
holds
okay
so let me tell you the general strategy
here
so the general strategy is that i'm
going to give you a graph and a set of
treatment vertices to be intervened on
and then we're going to form the graph g
of a in two steps in the first step
each
treatment node is going to be split
so in the previous case that was a and b
we split those and we're going to split
it into a random half and a fixed half
then the random half will inherit all
the edges directed into
a in g and the fixed half will inherit
all the edges directed out of a in the
original graph okay so the fixed part
gets the child
edges and the random half gets the
parent edges
and then in the simplest scheme
we just relabel everything that is
downstream of this fixed node
in the graph after we make the splits
gets labeled with a with with that fixed
note so here
we get this
so everything that's downstream this is
a slightly busy figure but this is just
a schematic to show you refers to all
the splits and then everything that's
downstream of the fixed node a gets
labeled with little a
i'm also going to describe some other
labeling schemes this is a labeling
scheme that i call ancestral i'll we
will have described some other labeling
schemes
shortly but this is the simplest one and
it's also intuitive it's telling you
that essentially that these are the
variables that you can think might be
affected by setting a to a specific
value
okay um
so here's a summary so here how we can
can add across the bridge sort of from
dags to counter factory distributions we
start off with a graph g and observe
distribution p of v
we can we form the new swig in the way
that was described by node splitting and
then labeling that gives us the counter
factor distribution of p of v of a
and note that under the minimal or
ancestral labeling i just showed
not all the variables
in in the graph will be labeled with the
full set of things we intervened on
right so we saw that already here this
guy is labeled with a and b
but these these guys are not labeled
with both a and b and indeed this this
guy is not labeled with with anything
same with h
okay
and we assume
so the basically the model
assumes factorization of the count of
actual
variables uh we have this modularity
assumption that says essentially the
conditional density associated with a
random node in the new graph is just the
conditional density associated with that
with a node with the corresponding node
in the original graph
after substituting in the fixed value
for any
any uh treatment that was was a parent
of y just directly analogous to the the
previous example we saw the simple two
note example we saw
verification question is does this sweet
construction only work for atomic or
fixed interventions or does it work for
more general interventions so the
construction i'm presenting here is just
for thinking about static interventions
but the the machinery can also work for
dealing with uh
dynamic um
uh regimes but it gets more complicated
and uh yeah i i won't get into that in
that lecture in this lecture but this
the splitting idea that we've got here
we should think about that as static
interventions so for those of you that
are
wondering about that question the idea
is you could imagine
you know there's often interest in
thinking about a treatment regime where
you know
it's not that we just give everyone
a treatment at every point in time but
maybe we come up with a rule that tells
us to treat people based on how they're
responding to treatment initially
and so in that case you have sort of
dynamic
um uh counter factors with a regime with
a dynamic regime so the the framework
has been designed so that you can um
can accommodate those and indeed also
accommodate
dynamic regimes that that uh
that depend on the natural value that a
variable would take so for example you
know something like uh
um
a a regime where we
um ask people to do
to do
10 minutes of exercise per day or how
much exercise they would do usually if
that's more than 10 minutes per day so
we're not we're not telling people if
they're already doing 20 minutes of
exercise per day that they should
only do 10 minutes we're going to tell
them that
if they're doing less than 10 minutes
per day we want them to get up to 10
minutes per day but if they're doing
more than 10 minutes per day
um then then uh
they should go on doing what they were
doing or you know income supplement or
something like that income supplement
program would be another example
okay so
having set this up we can now um
we can now
think about
we can apply d separation to the graph
and i'm going to tell you that in two
stages so the first part
the first way uh that the sort of
the key thing
the red nodes the fixed nodes are going
to be relevant here
and the key thing to remember is that
we're never going to allow a red node to
be um
to be
a non-endpoint node on a path so any
path that goes through a red node is
always blocked it doesn't matter you
know
so we just don't ever consider paths
that have red fixed nodes
uh on them unless it's it's as
one
okay but for now
on this slide i'm going to think about
powers that start at a random node
end at a random node and don't pass
through any fixed nodes okay so if it's
a fixed node and it's not
uh
and it's in the middle of a path
it's a non-end point then that that path
is automatically blocked
okay so that's
so so
our definition of deseparace is
identical to the definition that we had
before except for the fact that
we never conditional and fix those and
we never allow parts that goes through
fixed nodes
so
uh for the purpose so in this slide i'm
talking about d separators being a
relation among three subsets of random
variables that occur in the swing
and so
yeah so so
i think a key point that maybe i
maybe i skipped over not sure yes a key
point i just wanted to make on the
previous slide is that
it follows from this factorization
modularity assumption if the whole if we
observe the joint distribution over the
variables in the original graph then
whatever swig we construct
the uh the distribution over the counter
factor random variables that the current
net swig is identified
so that all the graphs we're
constructing
correspond to
distributions over count factors that
are identified if
uh the given that we observe the joint
distribution over all the initial random
all the variables in the original graph
okay so this is just saying what
was implicit in the example that i
showed you if i give you a swig and you
look at three subsets of random nodes in
that swig and you say okay
i'm ignoring paths that go through red
fixed nodes just ignore them completely
and i have d separation then we will
have
uh
conditional independence in the
corresponding um counter factual
distribution
okay any questions at this point
maybe maybe i should do another let me
do a couple more examples
okay
okay so let's talk about jasmine for
confounding so this was already
described so i apologize that the next
hour and a half i'm going to they're
going to be the front door and back door
are going to be sort of gone over
several times so buckle up we're going
to do them we're going to do them both
twice but um
okay so here's here's the graph we think
of as being a situation where where
we're if we're interested in the effect
of x and y then we can con
we can
get that by using the backdoor formula
adjusting for l
okay so here
we start off with this graph we split we
get to this graph and then we can read
directly from this graph that x and y of
x
are uh conditional independent given l
okay and this this
uh if you have a kind of nutritional
biostatistician friend who doesn't use
grass
that does cause inference they will
recognize this they'll say oh that's
conditional ignorability and so they'll
see that
so you'll be able to explain that this
graph implies this uh
condition which is the condition that
um you know is sort of
understood in potential outcome terms as
being the situation where we can use the
backdoor formula okay and so you can
you can sort of see that here's that
little proof
right so here's uh
i'm interested in knowing this this is
the distributed over y when i intervene
to set x x tilde
this is total probability
then uh
the independence because i've got this
conditional independence i can add x
here
in this term because of this conditional
independence
and
now i use
consistency
to get
from here to here
and now i've got my identifying formula
okay
we can if if your friend says oh but
wait a second
you know what what happens if there was
a confounder an unmeasured confounder
between l and x
well if the as long as it was just
between l and x
then you know you can work out yep that
conditional dependence is going to
continue to hold
because now although we've got 2d two
paths between y of x and x
l is a non-collider on both those paths
so when i conditional now both of those
paths are blocked so we're going to get
this conditional independence and so yep
we can still use the backdoor formula in
that graph
or if it goes this way around
but we can also see that if we were
unlucky enough to have the hidden
variable uh
between l and x and a hidden variable
between l and y
then we would be out of luck because at
that point
the path y h
l up to the other hidden variable and
down to x
conditional on l
would
deconnect
so we can see that
in particular we can see that
that the um
that if we had two confounders then
we could not use backdoor adjustment
and even more strikingly and this is
sort of contrary to things that you
might read in in some econometrics
textbooks you can also see that if i had
a confounder between l and y
and an independent confounder between l
and x and i didn't have these two edges
see let me just draw this
okay so if i had
so if i had a graph that was x
xl by
h1
h2
right which would give me the swag x
little x
y of x
h1 h2
l
right we would see
that this graph will give us that x is
independent of y of x
but x is not independent
of y of x given l
and so
this is this is i think this is very
important this is one of the main
contributions of the graphical approach
is to be aware that this type of
situation can arise because there are
some i think it's older books but there
are some econometrics books you can read
that will say that essentially there's
no such there's
there is omitted variable bias so
emitted variable bias arises when you
have
uh when you have you know x is not
independent of y of x but this
independence holds
sorry i forgot to put it across
but
but those books will say
that it cannot be the case that you
would have
treatment was unconfounded marginally
but then when you condition on a
variable l that was could have been
pre-treatment
you end up
losing
ignorability
so
so i think yeah this is the fact that
this can arise is really important to to
be aware of and it from my perspective
this also motivates
graph learning algorithms
because
essentially
um you realize
that uh there isn't a kind of wiggish
inexorable progress to controlling for
confounding
you realize that you could be unlucky
you could have a set of confounders that
was sufficient to control from
confounding and then you add in another
variable and suddenly
you know
unbeknownst to you by adding in another
variable you've now
uh you've now
induced confounding
and then maybe you add in some more
variables and stop having confounding
then you add in some more and then
you induce confounding again whereas the
sort of the the
the false theorem that says that there's
omitted variable bias but there's no
such thing as variable inclusion bias it
leads this it sort of gives you this
idea of the inextricable match of
progress that i just keep on adding in
more and more and more confounders and
i'm never going to sort of
take a step backwards
okay
i want to say a word about labeling so
so up till now we just had this scheme
we started off with this graph i split
if i split on a and b
and i label then i then get this graph
there are situations where we want to
use other labeling schemes so one
labeling scheme would be for example
that i just label
that when i split everything that comes
temporarily
after
a given uh
node gets labeled with that so here for
example even though
c is not downstream from a
after we split b
not downstream from this fixed node i'm
still labeling with
with an a here and in this particular
case here
here i've just got uniform labeling
where i'm just labeling everything with
the fixed nodes
okay so the temporal or scheme
uh
so i i'm not going to be able to go into
a lot of details but basically the
temporal scheme the idea this is
motivated by the idea that
um
we might sometimes want to have missing
edges in our graph correspond to the
absence of a of an effect of a causal
effect at the population level without
assuming it's absent at the individual
level okay so remember this morning in
the simplest possible case where we were
looking at a treatment in a response i
made this point that
if the individual causal effect is zero
what does that mean it means there's no
one who has helped and no one who is
hurt
if the individual causal effect is zero
that means that the average causal
effect will be zero so the proportion of
people of type helped and hurt will be
equal
but
you know if the only data that i have
access to is from a randomized
experiment all i can do inference on
uh um you know the only thing i can
identify is the average causal effect
and so
so you know if i've got some reason to
think that an edge is missing but that
the the reason i
think that the edge is missing is
because it came from a randomized
experiment
then i might not want to assume that i
know that there's no effect at the
individual level okay and so i can use a
graph like this
to uh to represent the idea that i know
that that sort of a has no effect on c
uh after
uh intervening on b on average but i but
i'm not yet willing to i'm not asserting
that that's holding at the individual
level
of course
i could make i could adopt other
inferential principles like faithfulness
or various bayesian
arguments whereby i would say you know
but how likely is it things perfectly
balance out so that that that effect is
zero at the population level without it
being zero at the individual level i
could certainly adopt those things but
there are times where it's useful to not
um
it's there are times where we want to be
very precise and where we want to
see exactly what are the
exactly what is needed for given
inference and so for that purpose this
is useful
so this this kind of scheme so this kind
scheme can look a little bit nutty
because uh you know it's saying for
example
that um here
uh you know this potential outcome for a
we're allowing to potentially depend on
b even though b is something that takes
place later in the future
so
so you know it seems as if we're
violating the arrow of time here
one reason for this scheme is just there
are times where you want to be able to
unambiguously if i've got several
different swigs i'm talking about and
some of them i'm splitting different
subsets of variables it's just useful to
have a scheme that lets me talk about
which variable is in which graph whereas
if i look at this you know if i tell you
i'm looking at b of a
um you know you don't know whether or
not that's b of a in the graph where i
split a
or b of a in the graph where i split a
and b so it's just useful to have this
uniform labeling scheme
for certain purposes
such as the one i'm about to show you
okay
so i'm going to go through this next uh
this next part
a couple of the next slides are sort of
assuming that uh
you were here on tuesday and saw
spencer's a great presentation of um
to do calculus but before i did i have
to give you one more definition so up to
now we've talked about deconnection and
deseparation between random nodes
but
there's also some uh utility for
thinking about the absence of
deconnecting paths
where one endpoint
is a fixed node
so
so we'll say that a path on which one
endpoint is a fixed node
that it can deconnect to a random node
if it satisfies the usual conditions on
colliders and non-collided so that means
uh
as before all of the colliders and long
colliders must be random we're not
allowing any
nodes on the path except for the end
point
to be um
to be fixed
and we're having the usual conditions on
on those
those
on those variables question
at least
okay
so if if a fixed node d is d separated
from a node b of a d given c of a d
then it will turn out that the
conditional distribution for b
given c
um does not depend on
the
the value to which d is fixed so in
other words the conditional distribution
b given c after intervening on a and d
does not depend on the value assigned to
d
so this is some more information that
we're able to read off from the swing
okay do calculus so as you
probably may know or thought you saw on
on
tuesday pearl formulated a set of three
rules that uh
gave the allow three transformations so
one says
you know when is it the case that i can
if i've
the districts of y when i see z and c w
and do x when is it the case that seeing
z doesn't change that distribution
um
and that here this is just sort of
helpful practice to translate this into
potential outcomes this is what that
statement looks like in terms of
potential outcomes right so we
do x everything is labeled with x
and then um we're just saying when can i
drop when can i drop the random
variables out there
the second one was about when could i
interchange observation and intervention
so here
we go from this to this we basically
what changes when we cross here is that
we get uh
we go from here having
seeing zed to hear intervenion said so
potential outcome language that just
corresponds to this uh um equality so
you can see it on the left we
conditioned on z of x on the right we've
now intervened on z
so we get w everything is labeled with
little z here
and we could remove interventions right
so in
do like do language we just get to drop
the do potential outcome angle you just
drop the z
okay you'll also remember that uh pearl
gave some rules for reading these things
off and those corresponding to checking
these separations in various graphs and
you know there was a graph this graph
for the first rule this graph for the
second rule and then this graph which is
a bit complicated to be honest for the
um for the third rule
so the good news is if you didn't
totally take this all on board
there's no harm because uh we're going
to simplify this so that you don't need
to
you can do everything just with with
swigs
and you don't need to remember these
complicated definitions
okay so here are the rules
so the first one the first one is sort
of fairly easy
we just say well when are these two
things equal well that's when y of x is
d separated from z of x given w of x in
the switch
it's just you know this is just
conditional independence in this week
second one is
when is it the case that
i can switch from
from intervention to
observation
and that
that holds when y of x said is d
separated from z of x said
given w of
x here i should say
in these rules i'm using the the uniform
labeling where i'm labeling everything
so that precisely so that you can tell
which suite we're talking about okay so
um
okay and you could also
just as an aside
uh you could you could also derive this
actually from
this first rule and consistency if
you're a counterfactualist and familiar
with consistency then you can sort of
read this off but you can also think
about this as an instance of um
an instance of
uh
ignorability
ignorability plus consistency
and then the even better news is that
the third rule
we're going to replace the third rule
with a much simpler rule which just said
if z has no directed path to y of x said
in g of x said
then these two distributions are the
same
so that then dropping dropping z is not
going to uh change the minus or
distribution of
um
of of y
okay so this this still may look a
little bit
cluttered because we've got x all the
way through so everything here was
assuming that in the background we were
intervening on x
and because really this is
very simple
um so alexander has a question i think
i'm going to take that at the end
because i've only got 10 minutes left uh
so so basically um in terms of
um
here yes so here i hear all the way
through we're interviewing x so just to
show you to sort of reduce this down to
to make absolutely clear what's going on
we're just going to consider the case
where we where you know we suppress the
interventions on x
this is why i call the tldr version
so the
rule one just corresponds to the
separation
raw two
corresponds to uh to d separates the y
of z from z of z the natural value of z
given w of z
in the graph where n to v non-z so this
is just generalized ignorability
and then the last one is simply causal
relevance okay so the reformulated verse
is just three things de-separation
ignorability
currently this independence
and interventions only affect causal
descendants
okay i think that's
yeah so i think that's somewhat
simpler than uh than was
the original formulation
and i should say yes this is joint work
with uh dan malinsky
and uh
ilya
with also some
inspiration from
jamie
okay
so
here
um
yeah so let's let's just show how we can
derive the front door
okay so this is the graph front door
graph i think yeah
these are maybe labeled they were
previously being called spencer had
different names for the variables but
it's the
same graph
okay so i want to know p of y of a
so just law of total probability lets me
uh
express that that way
and then now i can look at the graph
where i um intervene on a
look at this graph and i can see here
okay
i can see that
m of a
is d separated from a given empty set
so therefore i can use rule two to
replace this term with this term
then
i can now
i can now look at this guy
and i can say y of a
i i'm looking at the graph g of a m
and i can see that y of am
is d separated from
m of a
in the graph where i intervene on um
on a and m
so therefore that tells me that uh
that tells me that this guy this is my
rule two this guy is equal to this guy
so i get to do that replacement
then
now looking at this graph i can now see
that
[Music]
i can see that
in the
in the graph where i've intervened on a
and m
that uh
um there's no directed path from a
to y of am so i can just drop a from
this i get to this term
and then
finally
uh um i can so now i so now i'm pulling
the p of m a out to the to the front and
then using law of total probability
again to re-express this term like this
just law of total probability
and then uh finally i could can use the
fact that
um
that uh
a
is um
that in the graph where i
um
in the graph where i
uh get so y of m is is d separated from
m given a
so consequently i can now
um
i can now go from
from here to here
so this is just using rule2
okay so this slide is in here uh in case
there are people that you know you you
you went through the derivation you
carefully memorized this on tuesday
you're thinking to yourself you know
well this seems like a you know how
could it be that we could simplify this
the reason it's possible to simplify
this is that in fact
uh many instances that uh that pearl's
rule here actually splits that into two
parts
zeds that are ancestors of w and z's
that and ancestors of w and it turns out
that we can um
it turns out that any z that is an
ancestor of w when this when the
condition that holds in pearl's rule
applies then it's possible to use rules
one and two to already remove
those uh that that part of
any part of zed that is an ancestor of w
in the graph where uh where we've um
uh where we split on
uh on x this is a typo it should be g
sub x bar here
in these cases okay so that's why
it's possible to simplify this because
actually
um
a lot of
z can already be removed using rule one
and rule two
and then the remaining cases we just
left with variables in z that are not
ancestors of w which then makes the
condition much simpler
okay
okay so just the last little bit here
i'm going to talk about multiple
treatments
it's just to give another example of
this so this is a graph there was a
question asked yesterday which is can
you give us a concrete example where we
would know that a particular graph holds
and so this is a this is sort of the
sequentially randomized trial example so
the idea is i've got two treatments a
and c the first treatment is randomized
the second treatment is randomized
conditional on the observed history a
and b
but b and d are responses and they may
be confounded by the patient's
underlying health status okay so the
great thing about this graph is we could
make it hold by design if we randomly
assigned a
observe people how they respond be then
randomly assign c can d based on their
observed history so the probability that
they get c may depend on their observed
history we could make this graph hold by
design okay
and now what we want to do is given that
we did this experiment we would like to
know the distribution over d when we
intervene on
a and c
okay so the old results of uh jamie's
say that if these two independences hold
then we can use this expression instance
of the g formula to identify this okay
i'm going to give you in the last
lecture i'm going to show you how to
derive this
but for now just suppose that you know
you had your friendly epidemiologist who
said i learned in fp101 that we cannot
we can solve this problem if these
independences hold
but somehow they you know they didn't
they didn't they they skipped the
lectures on swigs in happy 101. um so
questions does this uh do these
independences hold
well we can just split and we can then
read off
that a is independent of a obviously
doesn't have any nodes into it so
obviously this is d separated from this
and then it just remains to check is
this independent of this given this and
this
and the only thing we have to remember
is that although it might look like
there's a path through a this is a fixed
node and we never allow
paths that go through fixed nodes so we
only have to worry about powers through
b of a but if we're conditioning on b of
a then b of a is a collider
and so
this d separation holds and we can apply
the formula
so perl has a twin network approach this
is i'm not gonna don't have time to talk
about this in great detail but the twin
network approach would involve drawing
this graph in order to check those
conditions and it also this this also
corresponds to stronger assumptions it
basically corresponds to making
additional
counter facts and dependence assumptions
that are cross worlds
and so
i'm going to skip that i'm just going to
end up by saying
yeah i want to make a quick comment
about relating this to count
counterfactuals and structural equations
because a i sort of deep comment that
spencer made on tuesday where he said
the structural cause of models and then
we're looking at the
shadow
causal bayesian network shadow
and so
so this is you know this is what a
structural equation model looks like
each variable is expressed as a function
deterministic functions parents plus an
error term
um
you know but we could rewrite that in
terms of potential outcomes like this we
just sort of
if we just put the
we can think of each equation as
essentially just specifying the
potential outcomes and then we get our
observed variables back by sort of
recursively substituting so we get our
random value of x and then we stick it
into here that gives the value of m
then we stick those into here that gives
us the value of y
okay
so
so you know so we can map backwards and
forwards between structural equations
and potential outcomes
um
so perl has often said that these these
these uh
that uh
that um
that structural equation models and
potential outcomes are equivalent
theories i should say this is a
structural equation models and things
and outcomes are equivalent theories
they are
uh that's that's true but the issue is
that usually when uh uh people put down
on parametric structural equation models
they tend to assume that errors are
independent okay so so if you say that
there's no confounding then people will
typically make the error terms
independent and the point is that
that assumption of independence of areas
corresponds to making a lot of
cross-world
and hence untestable counterfactual
independence assumptions so sort of
here's the simplest case said and why
if everything's binary we would have
these seven counterfactual random
variables
uh um
structural causal model assumes
cross-world independences typically i
mean assuming you don't put in
bidirections if you just draw this graph
without bi-directed edges
it's then assuming that this is
independent of both of these and both of
these are independent of all of these
and so that means that we're putting in
place a lot of independences we can
quantify exactly how many independences
are being made
so if you if you made no assumptions
then we've got seven random variables so
we've got a distribution of dimension
127.
the swag defines a model of dimension
113.
the non-parametric structure gradient
model with independent areas defines a
model of dimension 19. so there are 94
the difference between these two is 94
so 94
additional counterfactual independence
restrictions that are being made by this
model the structural causer model and
you know
if you want to think in terms of
computational complexity this grows
pretty quickly okay so once we're up to
four variables
the number of additional tests one
uh untestable independence constraints
the extra independence constraints that
are being made by the structural causal
model
is in you know 32 000 um so
yeah
so summarizing
the structural causal model independent
air assumption it can't in general be
checked by a randomized experiment on
the variables in the graph i think
that's a problem because the whole point
about
the whole renaissance course of
literature in the 20th century was sort
of where we got away from canned was
when people started
thinking about cause and effect in terms
of experiments that could be carried out
that's sort of gone when we do this
yeah
people might say but hold on don't you
do causal discovery doesn't that require
faithfulness yes it does but
faithfulness is a bet it's a bayesian
assumption that
if we see a constraint it didn't arise
due to chance it's a bet
it's not metaphysics the problem is
that
that
that
in parse framework
if you put down non-parent restriction
equation model it often seems as if the
act of just writing down the dag
licenses making these untestable
assumptions
okay
i've run over time
but i'll stop you
thank you um
just in the chat there were two
questions actually that both were
high-level questions asking i think
about whether there is a preference
uh for particular tasks when you should
use the potential outcome framework
versus other tasks where the graphical
model framework
might be better
okay so so i think uh you know
this is like uh
this is like the question how many
foreign languages should you know or how
many languages should you be able to
speak
i think um
uh
you know
i i have a fairly unambiguous answer
there that the more you know the better
it is
there are lots of things that it's very
hard to express in terms of it's purely
in terms of
of of um in in any one language okay i
mean if we want at a high level if
you're trying to think in terms of
causal
uh so
what are the downsides of potential
outcomes
as i said going back to this
people spent a long time working with
potential outcomes and
there were a priori
you know statements which sort of ruled
out that said this this was impossible a
prior it was impossible to have
you know no confounding nicely but
confounding when you're conditioned or
not so that shows there's a blind spot
because we can easily describe the
scenario where that arises
you know i don't think this is a
scenario that arises very often but
logically it's perfectly valid scenario
we could easily imagine this this
arising so potential outcomes have their
blind spots
on the other hand there are lots of
distinctions that can be described in
terms of potential outcomes that it's
hard to describe in terms of of of dags
and just think about something like the
assumption that there are no defies in
our iv setting if there are no de fires
then suddenly we get
we get a identification
um there are
um
yeah so so i think basically
uh the other point is
it's not clear to me what it means to
say the graphical framework because
there are different graphical frameworks
that's the structural causal model
or non-parametric structural equation
model with independent errors and then
there are causal bayesian networks so
you know there's more than one graphical
framework out there
um uh
uh so yeah so so anyway so that's my
basic answer my basic answer is you
should try to use both and swigs are a
way to try to make it easy for people to
use both
um you know i think that uh there are
yeah i mean the the genesis of this uh
one of the reasons i
want was motivated to come up with this
was i taught teacher course on causal
modelling with uh michael hutchins from
um
unc uh biostatistics we were both he
would teach finite population inference
and the reuben course model and i would
teach graphs and people came up
afterwards in the break and would say
you know this was great we really
enjoyed it
uh um but is there any connection
between these two approaches and so this
is partly an effort to show that there's
a connection between these uh these two
um yes so uh
um
okay comment about faithfulness was it
uh metaphysical yes i was i'm not sure i
said so i mean it can be viewed in
different ways one way of viewing
faithfulness is to view it as
um
i was viewing it as an assumption it's
an inferential principle which is to say
that you know i'm going to think that if
there's a constraint that arises i'm
going to bet on
i think it very likely that it arose due
to structure rather than
due to perfect cancellation but
there are very there are settings where
we know that that's that's not uh
correct so for example
homeostasis and
homeostasis uh
you know it's quite an important
property of many organisms especially
mammals that the external temperature
can vary
but their internal body temperature
is is does not vary you know within a
reasonable range it doesn't just doesn't
vary so much you know that's how
homostasis is maintained so whenever you
have feedback systems good engineering
involves trying to build feedback
systems so that
certain kinds of external stimuli don't
uh change the underlying state so there
are situations where you know
faithfulness is where there's going to
be a
mismatch between the conditional
independence structure and the
underlying causal structure
do you want to
i'm a bit undecided how much we want to
keep the kids going right now so maybe
we'll stop this here and take it offline
and take a break for 20 minutes until 3
30. um
are you willing to ask me
oh yeah